hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and today we're
going to do some styling and some UI
changes to make this app look a little
nicer as you can see there's no video
right now so I don't know why I
I moved so I moved into my new house I
unplugged everything moved all my
computers over plug it back in and my
webcam now does not work so I'm
installing some stuff from the
manufacturer that hopefully will help it
says it's gonna finish in about a minute
so the video may turn on it may not but
y'all don't watch this for my face
anyway
so let's get started as long as you can
see the screen and hear me I think
that's that's good enough
I'm gonna check real quick and see what
everyone's saying in the chat
hey everybody see a lot of people were
just saying hi how's it going okay let's
bring up the app first so that everybody
who hasn't seen it yet can at least see
it also so the hit the installation just
finished so let's see oh okay no I don't
want to sign up for this Wow all right
so I don't think that did anything
because nothing happens
hey we've got something that's weird
there we go it works hey let's move it
over so it's there we go okay so I guess
it was just a driver or something you
can see my background has changed so
this is my new place I'm thinking about
getting a fish tank back there so I have
a fish tank with some goldfish I haven't
moved it yet
so I don't know let me know what you
think if you want to see my goldfish
behind me anyway alright let's get
started so I do want to give a shout out
to Chris who did a awesome pool request
so let's do get pool this is gonna pull
down all those changes from the portion
you can see like the the code changes
immediately there so this is a decently
significant pool requests especially
considering the project still small this
is quite a few changes - thank you Chris
we're also gonna do yarn this is a good
practice any time you start a project or
I'm sorry any time you're working on a
project first thing you should do is do
a git pull soon as you you start working
on in the morning you know do git pull
do and then run yarn or NPM install that
way you know you have the latest you
know changes and and the packages right
like I've forgotten this before
and I start working realize they don't
have the latest changes and then there's
like merge conflicts and stuff or I do
remember to pull but I don't remembered
it to run yarn and install the packages
and then I get all these errors and for
a second I'm freaking out before I
realize that oh I just didn't install
the new packages so so let's start this
up that way we can see the app so we'll
be able to see it and also let's go to
the pull request so the issues now
there's only two issues left I'm sure
we'll we'll be able to add some more but
with a closed pull requests and check
out this one right so I'm not gonna go
through all of this just so that we have
time for coding but check this out the
link to the the repo is in the
description so you can check out but
basically this fixes two problems one we
had said that we don't want the user to
get the same question in a like the
exact same question twice in a row also
we don't want when you're doing
subtraction we don't want subtraction to
result in a negative number at least not
in in the first the first level also it
found some bugs that I didn't realize
we're happening you can fix those as
well so that's awesome you can check
that out there you can check out all the
files that have have changed
add a little bit to the the prettier
config which is nice
I'll probably set up some like automatic
linting so that anytime anyone tries to
commit code it'll auto lint it and let
me know if you want to see how to do
that I can do it on a stream otherwise
maybe I just try to do it you know
my own and just have it set up but it is
kind of a cool setup I usually do it for
all my projects and it it avoids having
like weird commits where you have it
looks like you have a lot of changes but
they're not really changes it's just
like formatting things like a semicolon
or not using a semicolon or weird spaces
so anyway I had some questions about
that Auto lint so when I say like Auto
linting and Auto formatting I just mean
like as soon as you would do like a get
commit there'd be a pre-commit hook that
would run and it would go through all
your code it would check it to make sure
the syntax is correct according to rules
that we set up and then if it's possible
for it to just automatically change your
code to use the rules we set up it will
do that so it's it's pretty cool it
keeps a nice standard and it makes it so
that if you want to contribute to this
project you don't have to learn all the
rules you just code how you like the
code and then whenever you go to commit
it'll change it all and it looks like
there is some interest so yeah I'll
definitely show you how to do that maybe
on the next stream that's what that's
what I'll do so yeah it's a cool little
setup and let's see I lost my train of
thought what were you doing oh I wanted
to show everybody the app okay just so
you know the way this is gonna go we're
gonna do a little bit of coding and then
I'm gonna take a break and we're gonna
answer some questions and then at the
end I'll try to answer all the remaining
questions so if you have questions and
they're in the chat and I haven't gotten
to them I will get to them in in a bit
probably in about I don't know 20
minutes or so maybe less I'll go back to
the chat all right but this is the game
right so I'm sorry if there's a lot of
background noise my kids are all getting
ready for school they're about to leave
so I don't know how much of that the mic
is picking up
hey buddy you want to say hi I don't
know if they could see there hey have a
good day at school but yeah so I'm just
in my basement right now eventually I'm
gonna build like a legit office and
hopefully soundproof it but just moved
in last week so anyway these are the
styles we do have different colors for
each mode right but we just threw these
in here this is definitely not how I
wanted to look I still am not exactly
sure how I want it to look but I think
there's some improvements that could be
made
so let's first thing I want to do is
open up dev tools right so if you're not
familiar with dev tools the this is your
best friend as a web developer dev tools
will allow you to inspect things on the
page see the code make changes basically
they're like previews of changes that
only you can you can see hey Rafa I'm
live-streaming but my son one of my
son's was back there just like moving
all these barking so what I want to do
is see how this will look on a device
because eventually we want to make this
run on a mobile device as well as on a
desktop so we haven't actually checked
to see how this would look on a device
so let's just I don't know which one
I'll pick let's pick a small one just to
get an idea so this actually isn't
terrible I kind of thought it would be
worse since we hadn't had this in mind
at all but
it fits wow that's that's cool it
actually fits okay so just looking at
this right now I think for sure
the numbers need to be bigger and the
buttons need to be bigger I think the
the hero character the tear and the
enemy characters is here they're here
can definitely be smaller so the the
perspective this is a children's game
right so their attention is going to be
drawn to this when in reality like this
there's no interactions they can take
here it's so weird we're drawing the
user to an area that they can't actually
do anything with so I think we can we
can shrink this so this is this stream
is gonna be a little bit of design and
dev together right so I'm I'm a software
engineer I've done design before a bit
but I'm not primarily a designer so
usually I just jump in and start coding
and then figure out the design as I go
along if this were a real project on a
real team we'd probably have a design a
designer already do the design right so
let's for now let's see what this looks
like when we shrink these up and make
this bigger all right now I want to make
sure anything that a user would click is
really big right because it's gonna be a
kids game they're their dexterity is not
going to be as good maybe as the average
user potentially so we want to make sure
they don't accidentally click in the
wrong spot so right here I can see like
the submit button needs to be bigger and
there needs to be more space right so
let's let's do that now like so since
we're in dev tools we can try some
things out here without actually even
touching our real code so let's click on
he's actually it might be easier in this
case so like in the case of the numbers
we can definitely make them bigger let's
see so we can see all the properties
that are currently on we can CSS
properties that are currently on this we
have the font size of 28 pixels so that
actually is seems pretty big but as we
could see like it doesn't actually look
that big on that phone so if we click
that it will show us where in the code
we have the 28 pixels now unfortunately
since we're doing this with react native
web and it's coming through it won't
allow us to edit directly inline if this
was just a normal web app we could so
we're gonna have to override it and
let's go with still with 40 pixels it's
gonna seem pretty crazy to do 40 pixels
but I think it'll be good actually
because of the way the Styles get split
up I can't target a style so let's just
go back to our code really quick in this
case I think it might be easier to just
mess with our code directly normally it
is not so we do have our Styles down
here and I forgot we were using Comic
Sans Oprah we may change that it's a I
think since it's a kid's game it might
work okay so our character has a width
of 80 and 80 let's let's cut that down
right let's let's give that 40 and now
our math container
our math wrote so our math row has a
padding on the bottom of eight let's
duck bump that up to sixteen and then
our text size 28 we'll bump that up to
40 and we do have our inputs of I
believe this is our input for let's give
it a let's make it it just the square
will give it a height and width of 60
I'm I didn't finish my thought sorry
that's our input to put the answer to
the question let's save all that and
then see what it looks like now okay so
definitely different
we now have bigger text here we have
more space I forgot to make a submit
button bigger is this okay so we didn't
actually make the text bigger in here so
what we need to do that and let me check
my time to make sure I forgot to start
my timer so so what I started at 7:30 so
we've been about 20 minutes now all
right let me just get just a few more
minutes and then I'm gonna go to the
live chat and read through the chat
alright so for now let's let's make the
button a bit bigger and will make the
text inside the input match with this
text oh don't let me forget I need to
check out Cyprus so our testing suite
has now changed from using puppeteer to
using Cyprus so I want to give you a
preview of that and I forgot to last
time and what I want to try to do it for
sure this time so that was in addition
from from Harshit who I haven't seen in
the chat today so I don't think he's
here but he's been a big contributor to
to my streams for a long time for like
over a year let's see where is a button
I don't think we have any styles for a
button so we're gonna have to go up here
and see what we can do here okay so we
actually have the default styles for a
button so let's look up in the dock the
react native documentation with the
styles are four button so if you're
doing a react native project I
definitely recommend just just leave
read the react native Doc's open on your
tab on one of your tabs because I
reference it so much it's just no point
of me even closing it so here's the
button you'd see I'm pretty sure we just
copied this egg's exactly but what I
want to see is all the the props on
pressed I know it's just a little color
disable test ID okay so here's a cross
but what I want to see is what kind of
styles we could actually give this which
I don't know let's see let's just add
some styles and see if we can give it
one we may have to switch it up so you
can use touchable opacity or touchable
native feedback to give your button some
custom styles so we may have to switch
up to that that's what I normally end up
using anyway but for now let's just see
if we can do this so I'm just gonna do
an inline style just as a test we're
gonna add style
so in react native if you want to do an
inline style you can you want to use an
object right so we're doing style we're
putting our curly brackets which means
hey we're about to do some JavaScript
and then inside of there we have another
set of curly brackets which is
just normal JavaScript right it just
says like this is an object and then now
we're gonna do CSS as if we were writing
so like a we're converting our normal
CSS into JavaScript object syntax right
so we're gonna camelcase everything it's
key value pairs right so in this case
let's just say height if I can spell a
cou HT and we're gonna give it something
crazy so we just know we know that it
works right so tight 200 that's so this
would be obvious if it works and it
didn't right so it looks like we're
gonna have to change that and we can't
actually add a height to a button if
there is some way to add height to a
button let me know in the chat you know
but according to the documentation it
didn't look like we could I was hoping
there'd be like some props but it seems
like the only thing you can really
change style wise is the color okay so
I'm just gonna click on touchable
opacity so it's there and we can we can
check that out and if anybody wants to
read ahead I'm gonna put this in the
chat the link to touchable opacity if
you've never used it before you can
check out the docs basically you're just
making something clickable and react
native and you can give it whatever
Styles you want alright and I'm gonna
take a five minute break here so I'm
gonna set my my Pomodoro timer to five
minutes I'm gonna go to the chat and I'm
gonna answer some questions okay so I'm
just seeing a lot of people saying hi at
first
charming Mohammed says this is a very
good thing thank you oh you're welcome
I appreciate that
Akeem says is this a react thing yes yes
sir it's a react native web so it's all
react native syntax but we're actually
running
as a web app if you want to know why
we're doing like that watch like the
first two streams and I explain more the
benefits of doing that Eric says how can
I find your JavaScript beginner
tutorials so I haven't done a lot of
tutorials myself it's mostly live
streams and it's some streams are more
beginner friendly in some streams aren't
it just depends on what we're working on
that day but there are some awesome
beginner JavaScript tutorials on this
channel on the free code camp channel if
you do want to see my tutorials check
out my channel the links in the
description I don't do that as much with
my personal YouTube channel I'd love to
do more just hard to find the time but I
do have some tutorials on there for
beginners jellal says smile more bro you
look better right alright I'll try to
smile works the dog says bro I love this
channel oh thanks thanks yeah the free
cooking channel is awesome like not and
I'm not just talking about my stream
like there are so many really really
good contributors and just the variety
and quality of content on this channel
is I mean it's really amazing and it's
impressive like no one's getting paid to
do this it's all volunteer so it's it's
really cool and it's helped a lot of
people to get their skills up and get
jobs like including me
charming says pulling in pulling in
installing yarn before anything in the
morning is good advice been a victim of
such trust me you don't want to go
through the work before you pull yeah
for sure
bell Bellies sorry
Angelo's I'm sorry I probably miss your
name up let me know how I'm supposed to
pronounce it but says I can animate that
I'm not sure what your what your are you
offering to animate something and so let
me know what your income not exactly
sure what what you're saying yes you
asked if I have any plans to work on UJS
projects not right now I've I'm like
curious about you but I don't have any
immediate plans to work on it
maybe maybe I'll do it at some point a
creative girl says hi which one do I
have to learn a flexbox CSS grid or
maybe booth chef I have no idea when you
use them okay that's a good question
there are some answers there coding
techniques as I think flexbox is easier
it's it's Mel says I will go with
bootstrap but just know little flexbox
okay so they're not exactly comparable
right so bootstrap is an entire CSS
library that's you bring in its CSS and
JavaScript and there's a lot of like
built-in classes that you can use to
style an entire app or a website flex
box is a part of CSS and so is grid so
it's a part of just normal CSS you don't
have to import anything extra and it's
used for positioning right so back in
the day people use tables for
positioning or we used floats for
positioning but flex or flex box gives
you a nicer way to position like for
instance you can vertically Center
things on a page very easily with Flex
box right that was always really hard to
do before and not that it was impossible
but it was just more difficult grid is
another way
to align things on a page so it's not
exactly comparable so like if you
learned all of bootstrap you could style
an entire site if you learn flexbox you
could just position things which you
couldn't really style things so I say
definitely if you want to do react
native then you need to know flex box
because flex box is the default
positioning system for react native so I
definitely recommend using flexbox
that's what we use and like bootstraps
are not always gonna be available to you
so you know try to learn the the regular
CSS it'll be easier to work on a variety
of sites if you know CSS bootstrap
should be easy to pick up because it's
just basically giving you chunks of you
know pre-written CSS attached to classes
that you can add to your site so if you
know really know CSS you'd be able to
understand
although bootstrap just by looking at
the CSS files and kind of know what's
what's happening and be able to change
it up and like customize it to what you
need does that make sense let me know if
it doesn't alright didn't get through
everything but let me go back to here's
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna say I want
to mark down here where I left off
you need to like adjust the tilt of my
screen or something it's really hard to
see I need new screens period I just I'm
using some old screens that I've just
gotten for people like when they're
getting rid of their screens
okay so let's how much time yeah okay so
have about a half hour left so here's
what I'd like to accomplish in that half
an hour I want to get the styling so I
want to get this button a little bit
bigger commit these new styles I'm not
like obviously we're not finished with
the styling but this is just a little
bit of some updates
I want to demo Cyprus for testing and
then I want to finish the rest of the
questions okay so that's the that's the
plan
so let's switch this up to use touchable
opacity first so we can see in with
touchable opacity obviously instead of
using Budig button we're replacing it
with this but then also we can put
things inside of it and in fact we need
to put things inside of it so let me
show you what I mean so right now our
button we can say like the title is
submit and look there's there's nothing
there's no children - this button when
we switch it to touchable opacity if we
did this
nothing would appear on the page right
so we need to give it children for
instance to say like hey here's what you
should display inside of this button
alright so let's switch that up now go
to the top of the file and where we have
button let's change it to
touchable opacity should have changed up
here - yep okay we're gonna change it to
touchable opacity now I know I'm gonna
need something in here and I will need
text and let's say oh wait is this or no
this was our restart button oh I changed
the wrong thing I forgot we hit I
totally forgot we had to restart button
all right let's do that again
let's keep button in there because I
don't want to mess with the restart
button right now just because I want to
finish on time right so let's touchable
opacity now let's find the right button
this time okay oh actually did we yeah
yeah this is what we did for a second I
was like have we been working on the
wrong button the whole time I don't
think so all right so touchable opacity
now we're gonna say text submit and then
we're gonna close out touchable opacity
hey no let me just say so we'll just see
what shows up on the page now before we
do anything else so you can see it's
it's just the button right so it should
still work so like right there's no and
you know I just thought of we should not
allow a submit if there's nothing in
here I can see that being really
frustrating for a child if they
accidentally hit submit and haven't even
put anything in there and then another
enemy comes like that especially if a
child is really struggling with their
math and it like almost beat beat it and
they know what the answer is and they
just accidentally hit submit like that
could be devastating for a little kid
right like so let's make that happen so
that we check to make sure that
basically if there is
nothing in this box we don't allow uh
submit all right we're not gonna do that
right now but let's just keep that in
mind and add that in at some point if
somebody wants to make an issue for that
feel free to make an issue I'll try to
remember and make an issue for it later
okay so we need to style this the submit
button right now so you can see like our
color you know that's not that's not
gonna work right we do so want to keep
this test ID I believe the title is not
gonna matter here we can double check
that there is no title attribute let's
see if it shows yeah so our props here
style activity okay
actually this is kind of weird why do we
have
it's really they don't list on press
under this I guess maybe they're just
like assuming that you would have that
but anyway we can remove oh yeah okay
Zico you can definitely remove the color
let's give this a style the style equals
and let's say styles dot we'll just call
this button for now and then we're gonna
have we have more than one button but
we'll just say styles that button and
I'm gonna rope this I'm gonna put this
under input since it appears under the
input all right so we need to give this
like a height width a background color
right so let's say our height is gonna
be at 40 pixels so we always want to at
least go 44 touches you know let's go
let's at least bump it up to 50 right I
want to make this bigger than you would
normally make it for an adult like I
said I know kids fingers are smaller but
they may be a bit more clumsy with let's
just go with with like a hundred for now
see how it looks and then background
color we can give it that same color
that we had I'm not like a huge fan of
that color but I don't really have any
other color in mine so in hey so I'll
just use it
okay let's see what that gives us Hey
look we've got a button okay you can see
like look it's still just totally
bare-bones the the submit is not even
centered so let's work on this submit as
well yeah okay
so we can actually set this to just I
don't know if I don't think I need to
put display flex on here but let's see
so let's say justified content center
and a line items center so this is
flexbox so this is what I'm talking
about when I say flex box makes
vertically aligning things easy so this
is gonna vertically in horizontally
center submit hopefully let's see yep
here we go so now it was up here now it
is both vertically and horizontally
centered so easy especially if you
remember everything that you had to go
through to make this happen before flex
box so much easier alright now we want
to make our text a little bit more
readable so we're definitely gonna give
it a color of let's just say white for
now
alright so FFF is gonna give us white
that's the the hex code and let's make
the font size so the button itself is
what's 50 so let's make our font size is
40 I definitely don't want it to be
bigger
and see what it looks like oops we
didn't apply it to the text so on the
text here let's say style equals styles
dot button text whoa okay we need to
make that wider and okay yeah definitely
need to make it wider and probably
taller yeah all right so the button now
is 100 let's double it to 200 and let's
make its high 60
okay that's more reasonable it's still
not like a spectacular looking button
but it does to have a little effect
right it has this little kind of flash
thing right and it still works all right
I tell you truth like I I'm not thrilled
with the way this button turned out but
it allows us to customize it so we can
further customize this as we we need to
right
let's see yeah that I'm kind of thinking
that the submit button is like
dominating the page now I mean you want
to keep track of my time okay but I
think I'm at a point now where I want to
commit this and and then check out the
testing suite so that I have enough time
to get to the like the the messages the
chat messages okay so so if if you're
totally a beginner and you're not really
familiar with version control we're
using git okay so we have get status and
that tells us what's changed right we've
only really worked on one file right so
that's to be expected and now we're
gonna do a git commit and I'm gonna give
it an AM flag okay and then I'm gonna
put the commit message so I'm gonna say
future this is like a terrible message
but we just adjusted styles right so
let's commit that and now we can do a
git push right and that's gonna push
that up to github right okay so that's
like very very basic of using git you
commit and then you push now we
basically have a save point for our code
that we could always go back to that
point later on so if we totally mess
things up in the next stream it's okay
because we could always go back to this
point all right now let's check out our
package JSON for a second and see that
we have
this e 2e script and that's gonna open
up Cyprus and run some tests okay so
let's let's check this out serve
everyone yarn e2e and like that I
haven't really used Cyprus yet so harsh
it set this up I think it's really cool
I did run it once just to see what it
did but it's definitely something that I
want to learn more about because it's
pretty cool so while this is doing its
thing which there we go so you see this
is definitely different than what we had
a test before before our tests would
just run and you know display some
things here in the console but this is
bringing up this whole UI right so it
says here's our test here's our file
right oops
this is cool
alright so I click that and now it's
running I didn't mean to actually run
them but so I clicked on that file and
you can see it's run all the tests in
that file so we only have one file with
the test I'm assuming if we had more it
would show all the tests and we could
run them all at once if we wanted okay
but if you saw some flashes up on the
screen of basically it was running this
and going through the motions of
clicking everything and it says we can
see a title we can see here oh and we
can we get the if we do a correct
Edition answer it reduces the enemies by
one right so we don't have a lot of
tests in there but it's kind of cool to
have a UI as well I know some of the
people I work with on my team are way
more familiar with UI stuff as opposed
to like filling things through the
command line so it definitely could be
helpful to be able to have that that
visual of this so you can see you know
recorded run yeah so there's a lot of
stuff in here
that I haven't even mess with Wow okay
so there's all your settings and your so
I mean this is really cool so definitely
check this out if you need to do react
testing wow really cool alright so I'm
not gonna go more into that yet because
I myself don't know that much about it
so I'd rather not mislead you but I
promised Harshit that I would demo it so
definitely you know check that out it
looks cool it does give us some output
in the command line as well
all right let's let's go back to the
chat so I've left about 15 minutes
before I have to end the show for chat
so I hope I can get through everything
before I have to end it okay so I ended
about to air in the chat about 646 my
time there we go okay and I'm gonna I
didn't really display what's changed in
our package.json so I'm just gonna put
that up here really the dev that's been
dependencies changed we have cypress and
our es lint plugin for Cypress and all
the stuff with like mocha and chai and
puppets you're gone all right so let's
get to these questions abdullah says i
am fresh to programming and i don't know
where to start check out free cookie org
and just start out with with some of the
lessons they're totally free just create
a free account and like free code camps
never gonna try to sell you anything
we're not gonna spam you with ads
nothing like that so just check it out
start doing some of the the the lessons
there and see how you like it web noob
says in response to creative girls
question about flexbox and bootstrap and
grid says everything is important to
learn
it yeah I mean ultimately yeah it's
great to know everything but I would say
like don't don't get overwhelmed
thinking that you have to learn
everything you definitely don't you know
if you just pick something and learn it
you're fine right so I would just try
not to be anxious about what to learn
what to learn first and in what order
you know just just learning something
and being able to work with it it's
great like a ton of websites use
bootstrap if you just know bootstrap
there's a ton of work out there the same
way like if you just know flex book and
you don't know bootstrap a grid you can
still do a lot of awesome things like so
basically my point is like as long as
you're learning something that's you
you're good you know you're already
going in the right direction you know
and you'll learn more eventually it just
you know it takes time Jimmy says guys
please can you help me out how can I
animate a button on long press I'm not
exactly sure that would be something I'd
have to look up myself so I can't give
you an answer right now
but maybe somebody else in the chat
can't web noob says hey Jessie are you
teaching your kids and programming can't
wait to try with my son yes so actually
I I do so we have like some little kid
programming books that we read to the
kids sometimes and we have like what
it's called
tinker so we have a tinker subscription
so I think it's like tinker calm or
something and they have coding exercises
for kids and so our kids do that so
we've tried out some other ones too but
my son especially my oldest my
nine-year-old seems to really like the
tinker stuff and he works on it all the
time so yeah so we're trying to teach
him and not like pushing them into that
into it but you know just kind of
providing them with books and
you know like lessons and stuff so it's
there if they want to want it you know
and they're just excited about using a
computer so if I tell them like well the
only way you can use computers if you're
doing the coding stuff then usually
that's enough and and they do it that
says rich-rich ba Bob I'm really sorry
I'm not pronouncing your name right but
says are you using the windows subsystem
for Linux no so I am using bash on
Windows but I'm not I haven't done
anything with the subsystem yet
za gaming says hello everyone hey how's
it going oh cool
so my michael krill answered my question
about the button and unfortunately I
didn't look over to see that but thanks
Michael basically says from Stack
Overflow
this component has limited options so
you can't resize it to a fixed height
all right so so that is true so
basically we did have to switch the
button over to a touchable opacity in
order to basically change anything
except the color tags for Farage NTS
says are you doing the mobile or web yes
so right now we're doing web but we're
gonna switch it over to mobile so let me
give you an update on that actually so
I'd like to use Expo to help us test and
build the mobile versions but
unfortunately so let me give some
background to explain this so like Expo
just takes has its own fork of react
native right and it allows you to create
react native apps more easily it comes
with a lot of built-in things too
- like developer tools and like
different components that work with like
hardware on a phone on a device so I'd
love to use Expo because it comes with
all that but since Expo has its own Fork
of react native it's behind a little bit
so it's not the latest version so the
latest version of react native allows
you to use react hooks which we are
using right but the Expo version of
react native doesn't yet support hooks
so if we try to use Expo right now we
would have to switch to not use hooks
and that would be a lot of refactoring
and I don't want to refactor it back to
that I'd rather use hooks so the plan is
this I'm gonna keep developing the web
version I'm gonna keep the mobile styles
in mind like by using dev tools and
mimicking the phone right but we're not
actually going to test it on a device
we're gonna wait for the next update to
Expo which should allow us to use hooks
then we'll pull in Expo into our project
and we'll be able to run the web version
and the mobile version the mobile and a
simulator side by side so that we make a
change we can immediately see how it
impacts both the web and mobile versions
so hopefully that makes sense we could
just use straight-up react native and
run it like that but like I really do
like everything the additional stuff
that expo uses so I'd rather just wait
on that if it seems like it's gonna take
a really long time then maybe we'll
rethink that strategy but that's where
I'm at right now so the mobile is coming
we're just kind of waiting on the next
expo update if anybody had notice like
if you've been keeping track of the
updates to Expo and you have some
insight into when that's gonna happen
let me know last week or something I did
read up on it
and at least at that point I don't think
there was an exact time for the next
release Syed says love you bro oh thanks
I love you too Vedant says this channel
is great man who says thanks thanks I
appreciate that man who says please
suggest hold on the movie this question
says I'm intermediate in JavaScript but
I can't build up logics what should I do
I check out some of the more advanced
JavaScript problems in free code camp so
freak ok about org I check those out I
know I keep recommending free code camp
but it's quality stuff and it's totally
free right if you feel like you need
more then maybe you know go look at some
of the paid things out there but free
code camps always a great place to start
there's always links to additional
resources on the free code camp lessons
so you can go and read more if you want
to but I would say yeah check those out
it's gonna you know give you some
algorithm problems and practice is
really I mean that's how you build up
your skills so just keep at it it'll
it'll be tough it's it's tough for me to
do the algorithm stuff and kind of the
more advanced like logic based off right
because as a primarily like web mobile
developer you know you're not doing a
lot of algorithm based stuff so you
don't normally get practice you kind of
have to go out of your way to keep up
and practice that stuff
JME says has have you ever told your
YouTube audience about how you got into
coding your challenges obstacles how you
got your first job etc it would be of
interest to us newbies so I have a
little so check out my youtube channel
the link is in the description I have
done some videos on like my background
and how I got into that so go ahead and
check that out if you check that out and
like there's something more specific you
want me to talk about let me know and
maybe I can make a video about that as
well but yeah that's a good question and
so I do have kind of a basic overview of
how I got into coding so that should
kind of highlight a lot of that
oh goodness um this somebody said in
response to the question about building
up skills and logic and stuff somebody
gave me the responsibility and codings
not really your thing so number one I
would say please don't do comments like
that you know we're trying to help each
other out so I don't really want
comments like that let's keep it
positive secondly but I'm gonna say it
again like practice is the difference
between people that can do things and
people that can't write there's not like
you know some people do have more
natural ability one way or another or
maybe their background gives them more
ability but it's still if you practice
you can get there so if something is
really hard that doesn't mean you should
give up or doesn't mean you can't do it
right it just means you more practice
right that's that's it so yeah don't
don't give up if this is what you want
to do then keep at it right and just
don't get discouraged I know it's easy
to say don't get discouraged but just
realize that like everyone goes through
times where they feel like they just
can't figure things out like I was
working on a bug on my work project and
trying to get something to work for like
over a week just trying and trying and
everything I tried just didn't work and
I just felt like I was never gonna
figure this out and then then I did and
it works it was and it was awesome and
my team was excited and my boss took me
to his boss and said here demo this
thing right and it was awesome right and
and but I really thought you know just
just like two days before I was like in
despair of ever finding a solution right
so it's just like you know keep going
and
you find a solution right I think people
that have been doing this for a long
time realize that you will always find a
solution eventually so you know don't
give up so but just in general everybody
try to keep things positive here you
know there's enough depressing stuff out
there in the world I don't want this
dream to add to that
it Graham says anyone know any materials
about music recommendation systems which
could be helpful to my college project
I'm really sorry I don't know anything
about that so I won't be able to help
you hopefully somebody in the chat can
all right so Jay says I'm confused
between Android and react what can I
start for a job purpose
okay so react is used normally for web
apps write react native can be used for
Android apps so you could start out by
just learning react and then transition
into react native to build things for
Android as well so it kind of depends on
what you want to do if you know you just
want to be an Android developer then
maybe you you just learn Android
development and just don't worry about
react at all but react is gonna allow
you to develop things for more devices
more platforms so that may be a better
path for a job but it just kind of
depends really on what you want to do
amana's can you use react navigation
with react native web so yes so the
navigation is a little bit tricky so you
can use any navigation that will work on
the web with react native web but when
you want to also do it on mobile you'd
have to have an alternate navigation
system that would work with mobile so
I'm actually I'm working with navigation
systems on another project right now
that's react native web and so right now
for the web navigation we're using react
router but for mobile it's really like
we have no mobile navigation system set
up we're just kind of using state to
navigate so like it's it that is a
little bit tricky I don't know of a
navigation system that would work for
both as of right now I'm hopeful there
is one because I'd like to use it but to
be honest I need to do more research on
it as well
all right I can listen I do want to say
like so I can see the the conversation
from earlier that kind of got took a
wrong turn there is going on so
everybody just kind of like chill so
they don't like you like you're cool
just like kind of like please don't tell
people to give up and then everybody
else that's getting on Vuitton like
let's just be cool about it - right like
and let's kind of just let it go for now
all right okay
Michael Creole says regarding coding
with her kids have you tried scratch yes
we have done some stuff with scratch
that's really cool so if you haven't
done anything with scratch even if
you're an adult coder like check it out
it's actually pretty fun it's kind of
like a drag-and-drop coding interface
it's it's cool Michael says if you have
an Android device you can plug it put it
in a debug mode connect it to your
computer and then dev tools can let you
interact live with your phone
yeah that's yeah we have done that I've
done that before so yeah we may end up
doing that but I do I want to do
something in a way that everybody can
see it on the stream so I don't want to
run stuff on my device
oh cool so Amon is a researching
navigation system that works on both
okay cool
uh uh if you find anything let me know I
definitely want to want to know more
about that
oh okay Michael Chris is saying that it
shows up live in dev tools so maybe that
might be something we could do where I
could test it on my android it would
show up live in dev tools you all could
see it as well okay so maybe we'll have
to do that Robert boy that's best
language you learned for beginners it it
depends on what you want really which
you really want to learn but assuming
you have no preference for what you want
to try to do I'm gonna say JavaScript
because you can run JavaScript in a
browser and you don't need anything
special on your on your computer right
so try that out like if you if you know
you want to do something different like
if you're not interested in web
development at all then like don't mess
around with JavaScript right um but if
you think you might want to do something
that has to do with web development then
go with JavaScript cuz you're gonna have
to learn it at some point anyway if you
want to do web dev alright okay so I
went over a little bit but I did get all
the questions in so anyway I guess will
be will wrap things up now I feel like
I'm forgetting something but I think we
did everything alright so thank you all
so much for watching I'm not gonna be
able to stream on Friday because I'm
gonna be at a conference so I'll be at
the Star Trek conference in Columbus
Ohio here in the in the US so I believe
my talk from that conference is going to
be online so whenever it gets posted
online I'll mention it in the chat I'll
probably post it on my social media and
stuff so if you liked what you saw here
subscribe and check out my channel
my social media and stuff links are in
the description if you have suggestions
for what I could do in the future you
know let me know if you want to
contribute to this project feel free you
can add issues you can submit pull
requests like the project's totally open
source if you have any other questions
that I didn't get to today you didn't
get a chance to ask you know put it in
the comments
set it to me on social media you know
I'm happy to happy to help so I guess
I'll see you all next week
until then have a great week and thanks
again for watching